the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so today we're gonna be doing a little
hands-on solar or wind turbine building
activity so by the end of if you guys
remember from the first bus wear lab
session where we cut and sawed things
apart using different hand tools well
the end product is supposed to be
something that looks like this it's
pretty simple the way it works is the
way it works is you have you have this
pen like this
wooden dowel on in your mounting of wind
turbine on it when you blow on there's
some destruction the spins it has some
magnets attached to the bottom and then
you're making coils with electromagnetic
wire and so as the magnets spin by the
coils you're inducing a current and
generating electricity we are just
starting to assemble this together
other snake yes if you guys feel like
changing your design at all because you
think something makes more sense we want
to make any improvements to the design
you should feel you don't feel like you
know if you follow these directions like
every step of the way okay
we have to come between them yeah yeah
yeah but do we need something in between
these two
wait are you doing all four coils
first you should do all four coils so
one event but make sure you leave space
like wire between the clothes you do
something yeah but I mean like drop more
wire between machine yeah cuz you want
to like you want to land like that and
so you just need enough wire to go from
here to here well I mean you could just
like you could just pull alright you
could just say leave this much wine and
then start your next well like
okay should I wake up I need to wrap in
a few of these okay ready
oh nice do you look lovely
this is definitely not for manufacturing
oh it's we glued it to it a little it's
now hitting them oh good nice ah we're
so clever
there's 17 ohms across it which probably
makes sense for the amount of tiny wire
we have
now we're measuring amperes there you go
that was a mistake
do some types of street
see that one moving